okay stay here because this is wild
controversy is actually swirling around
the Obama Presidential Library it was
supposed to be administered by the
National Archives only the Obama
Presidential Center is going to contain
no books it's more like a privately
operated entertainment campus with a
recording studio he's still dining out
on that Al Green thing he did years ago
that that karaoke and I guess he's gonna
have his era workout room or basketball
court now a growing number of people are
objecting to its construction on what's
historic partland parkland and one of
them is Charles Birnbaum he's a chief
executive of the cultural landscape
foundation he joins us from West Palm
Beach
obviously not Chicago but he's
spearheading this effort on behalf of a
lot of Chicago residents Charles no
books I don't know we don't know where
the archives are the documents I mean
explain this well first of all our thank
you for covering this this is a national
story and we are at the cultural
landscape Foundation are grateful that
you have picked this up so tremendous
kudos you're right it's not a library
what it is is a bait-and-switch
what Chicagoans were told when this went
to the park board that we would actually
have a library and the confiscation of
parkland held in public trust for a
hundred and fifty years was offered up
and now what we're seeing is a private
enterprise in the confiscation of public
parkland this is pure and simple it's
outrageous by the way it's really ugly
it's really ugly too
I'm sorry it looks like some I don't
know what it looks like it looks like
some kind of spaceship it's it's not
attractive I don't understand that Rahm
Emanuel we it was a very short segment
I'm gonna have you on radio tomorrow on
this but I guess Rahm Emanuel basically
said whatever you need correct whatever
you need to Obama they wanted a this big
swath of land whatever you need
this was actually land that the the deal
was made with the University of Chicago
imagine when this competition was
happening at Columbia University said no
we're gonna take nineteen areas 19 acres
at a park they would have been laughed
at all right
continue this on reading yeah it's
ridiculous